[Musique]
ici on injecte de co2 pour la
carbonatation une fois que c'est fait
séjour d'embouteillage à la brasserie la
ferme
une petit et jeune entreprise qui
cultive aussi une partie de son houblon
et ses céréales nécessaires à la
fabrication de sa bière exactement pour
moi de bouteilles qu'on utilise le choix
du contenant s'est rapidement imposé
dans leur plan d'affaires on était un
peu au sco ce qui est aussi vraiment
important pour nous c'est l'aspect
environnemental on a consulté des études
on essaie de comprendre qu est ce qu
était le meilleur en t2 convenant puis
intervalle la conclusion que la
bouteille réutilisable parce qu'on
l'avait noté c'était le meilleur choix
d' selon recyc-québec le contenants à
remplissage multiple comme la bouteille
brune génère des impacts
environnementaux significativement
inférieur à celui à remplissage unique
comme la canette en aluminium notamment
parce que cette dernière n'est pas
produite au québec donc le résultat
final la bouteille à remplissage
multiple elle peut être utilisée
minimalement dix fois parfois plus de 25
mais il ne convainc pas tout le monde ce
que vous êtes déjà fait dire par un et
ailleurs on voit pas d'où tu ailles ah
oui c'est un rêve et des italiens qui
ont fait le choix de vendre et de la
cagnotte
dans ce supermarché on accorde une
grande place aux produits de la bière
peu importe leur conflit
sur les deux étages de deux étages même
si justin le propriétaire trouve que la
bouteille représente bien plus grand
casse-tête qu'est ce que ça vous prend
comme une ressource gérer ses bouteilles
je vais avoir un employé qui vont payer
la conscience après son niveau de la
manutention pour pour la transporter
dans l'entrepôt ça va nous prendre des
contenants une boîte ou quelque chose
comme ça pour pouvoir les classes et
après ça il faut la retourner à la
compagnie et des fois c'est des
microbrasseries que je vois pas toujours
voir je me retrouve que je maintiens de
l'inventaire de conseil et détaillants
trouve aussi qu'il est plus simple de
mettre en valeur la canette qui prend -
espace notre job c'est de vendre de la
bouffe on n'est pas foutu on fait notre
bon travail de citoyen corporatif de
terrain récupérateur payeur et de
pouvoir retourner tous ces complots mais
c'est pas notre fonction première
la bouteille brune à remplissage
multiple c'est au coeur du plan
d'affaires de noël gaultier débuté hier
et dans des cases après ça les
embarquent sur un convoyeur dans cette
nouvelle usine à la fine pointe de la
technologie ont recréé plus efficacement
et à plus grande vitesse une opération
qui a fait ses preuves au québec depuis
le début du 19e siècle sont entrés dans
la brousse sont lavés 80°
la beauté c'est cac était en paix une
vie sans voix dans un bac qui sans
embaucher un conditionneur de verre qui
vont nettoyer refonde le vert
on prend la tête en petites billes qui
vont être vendus chez les verriers pour
refaire des bouteilles donc quand on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'aspect
circulaire vraie merde dans l'éternel
divers mécènes une bonne exempt noël
gauthier croit aussi que les contenants
à remplissage multiple ont un avenir
certain en raison des problèmes actuels
d'approvisionnement on pense qu'il va
avoir quand même beaucoup de rupture à
partir de 2022 23 au 24 dans l'aluminium
autant dans
dans le vert ce qui nous permet de
croire que le réemploi va donc créer de
l'emploi de l'économie mais aussi voire
éviter des ruptures de marchandises de
bouteilles dans les prochaines années
pour ce qui est de la bière là il n'y a
pas de changement québec annoncé que les
bouteilles de bière pourront toujours
être retourné aux commerçants en plus
d'être rapportés dans des nouveaux
centres de dépôt
cette spécialiste craint toutefois que
les besoins des brasseurs qui utilisent
ces contenants réutilisables ne soit pas
pris en compte lorsque la consigne sera
élargie car les bouteilles de bière ne
font pas partie de la plupart des
projets pilotes si ces points de dépôt
là sont réfléchies de manière à intégrer
les contenants à remplissage multiple il
ya bien les trier aussi pourquoi qu'il
brise pour qu'il soit facilement
identifiables ben là ça peut aider aussi
les détaillants qui ont des problèmes
d'espacé mais comme bien souvent le
choix du consommateur peut aussi envoyer
un signal si on est conscient et
consciente finalement du fait que un
contenant est réutilisé versus une
canette je pense aux côtés de
l'information qui est si connue que à ce
stade ci mais on peut faire des choix de
ce côté là mais évidemment il faut aussi
qu'ils aient l'offre sur les tablettes
contenant pour conteneurs je vais vendre
beaucoup plus de canettes et de
bouteilles de verre pour nous vu que
c'est une plus grande facilité du point
de vue de la gestion se sont convoi
priori
[Musique]
la lpi hev un brassard sont à l'honneur
mais c'est ce qui se vend le plus bas
qu'on a fait si tout le monde m'en
doutais pas correctement l'impasse
[Musique]